[Music]
big corporations and businesses there
well always seem to win no matter which
government is in power humans won't stop
traveling and reclamation is the only
way to be close to the airport right now
so will there be more coming absolutely
over the next four or five years you
will have probably another 6070 visits
here 150 lagoons started developing at
once there is so much of destruction
sedimentation to the reef and which
would definitely have a negative impact
on our Islands the International Airport
in the Maldivian capital Mali provides a
gateway for tourists from all over the
world
they're then taken by boat to the resort
islands that are just a short distance
from the airport that provides a
logistical advantage especially when
storms hit in just 15 minutes the
visitors arrive in Crossroads a mega
resort made up of nine islands a night
in one of these bungalows cost six
hundred and fifty euros two years ago
this was all just water satellite images
reveal how the artificial islands
suddenly emerged in the middle of the
coral reef Lagoon two and a half
thousand palm trees were brought here
from other islands if you didn't know
you'd think it had all developed
naturally those in charge of the project
are keen to uphold that illusion it's
still a natural island this sand
literally came from ten minutes away
from here so ultimately this is still
how islands are are formed all the palm
trees are from neighboring islands very
often because they were developing
something on the island say an airstrip
or or a construction
the whole issue of artificial islands
and replanted palm trees has long caught
the attention of the anti-corruption NGO
Transparency Maldives under a number of
deals reached by the previous government
nearly 60 coral lagoons surrounding the
capital Mali were leased to investors
they are now building more and more
artificial islands for tourists this
means the need for palm trees is growing
and they are in short supply as multi
vien law states that trees mustn't be
brought in from abroad why are these
trees being transported to the resort
not to the islands where there's no
trees there are so many islands which
have been reclaimed for the purposes of
expanding the land area for the people
to live and they're completely burned
like they don't have any plants any
trees transparency Maldives says that
tourism is given more significance than
the environment the country's
Environmental Protection Agency used to
assess tourism projects before they were
approved but the previous government
changed that time in the environment
especially if you consider the areas
closer to the capital Mali there are a
lot of reclamation and island making
going on I think we should not
concentrate making resorts near Mali
rather than doing that we should be
focusing on outer atolls
six new airports were scheduled to be
built this year and next to improve
access between the islands the island of
coho tofu she was stripped of most of
its mangroves to accommodate its Airport
but most of the time it stands empty as
it's not really needed the next airport
is just a 20-minute boat ride away
activists like Adam Abdullah take to
Twitter to report on the latest building
projects there using the Twitter hashtag
save Maldives to speak out and engage
with the authorities I think it's a huge
risk to base our economy on just the
tourism industry alone in order for
proliferation of tourism we're
destroying the very thing which our
tourism industry is based on these
coconut shells have spent nine months
soaking in the mangrove swamp to get
them soft enough to gain fibers used for
making rope for 400 women on the island
of Cohutta fishy it's the only source of
income one that is now drying up plans
are afoot to remove the islands last
mangroves to make way for a building
project seventy-year-old
eyeshadow Hassan has spent most of her
life making rope before the airport was
built the community was asked if we
wanted to keep the mangroves and
everyone said yes the politicians simply
ignored the residents wishes that's a
problem people on the island of Corrado
have been complaining about for 15 years
now their standoff with the authorities
concerns this channel of water sand is
to be taken from it regularly to
preserve the beaches of the resort
opposite its standard practice in the
Maldives residents on the island gain
nothing from the resort but sand is
being taken away from them Shazia Ali
from transparency Maldives says the
island is shrinking trees along the
coast are dying as the beach is steadily
of
roading she's collecting evidence in a
bid to give people here a voice but
they're fighting a powerful opponent the
current owner is also connected very
closely with some of the videos of this
country so it it would really be hard
for a commoner or a small community like
them this island to stand up and fight
against them I hope that with the new
government coming in they would
immediately like stop all the resort
development projects go but it's very
sad that a lot of this projects
continuing
you
you